[Music]
information systems operations
maintenance and support practices are
important to provide assurance to users
as well as management that the expected
level of service will be delivered
service level expectations are derived
from the organization's business
objectives IT service delivery includes
US operations IT services and management
and the group's responsible for
supporting them the sisa candidate
should have knowledge of service level
management practices and the components
within a service level agreement service
level management ensures that IT
services meet customers expectations and
that service level agreements SLA s are
continuously maintained and improved as
needed
SLA s are generally separate documents
from the contracts with external vendors
SLA may also be created internally to
assure the key process owners of the
level of service that the IT
organization has agreed to provide let
us continue to understand service level
management practices in the following
screen SFA's may include technical
support elements such as expected
response times systems availability for
example o eight hundred to eighteen
hundred Monday through Friday held for
Service Desk responses and escalation
procedures and so on therefore SLA x'
specify the underlying operational
specifics for agreed-upon services which
if measured and managed will deliver the
commitments that meet customer
expectations the main area of coverage
is IT Service Management we shall look
at is service management in the
following few screens IT Service
Management ITSM comprises processes and
procedures for efficient and effective
delivery of IT services relative to
business expectations to ensure ITSM
can be split into IT support services
and IT delivery services by teeth
support services include service desk at
times referred to as to technical
support help desk incident management
problem management configuration
management change management system and
infrastructure change and release
management IT delivery services include
service level management IT financial
management capacity management IT
service continuity management and
availability management although each of
these management areas is a separate
process by its own right each process is
highly interdependent with other
processes for instance repeated
incidents undergoing incident management
may require problem management to be
initiated resolving the problem may
require a change change management
process followed in infrastructure
configuration item which invokes the
configuration management process by
virtue of being a service organization
the success of the is department is
dependent upon satisfying users and
adhering to targets set within the
service level agreements a service level
agreement commonly referred by the
acronym SLA is an agreement between the
IT organization internal IT department
or external service provider and the
customer the business it details the
services to be provided for example
email ERP internet connectivity
internet website hosting etc is service
level agreements SLA assists in better
management of is services an SLA will
have various targets that will include
availability response time financial
performance such as ensuring costs are
produced and risk management through
compliance with company's policies
others include keeping staff turnover at
a particular number and overall
improvement in efficiency and
effectiveness we shall look at tools
that can be used in measuring
effectiveness and efficiency of is
service management
exception reports are automated reports
that identify all applications that did
not successfully complete or otherwise
malfunctioned they may indicate poor
application design inadequate operations
instructions operation support operator
training etc system application logs can
be generated from various systems and
applications should be considered to
identify all application problems the
size and complexity of these logs make
it difficult to manually view them there
are various programs that have been
developed to analyze and report on
defined aspects and items let us look at
other tools of measuring the efficiency
and effectiveness of an is operator
problem reports our manual reports used
by operators to log computer operations
problems and their resolution is
management should review operator
actions to determine if they were
appropriate and or whether additional
operator training is required operator
work schedules aren't reports maintained
manually by is management to assist in
human resource planning proper staffing
of operations support personnel will
assure that service requirement of
end-users will be met the sisa candidate
should have knowledge of techniques for
monitoring third-party compliance with
the organization's internal controls it
is essential to know the latest
approaches in contracting strategies
processes and contract management
practices outsourcing IT can help reduce
costs and or complement and enterprise's
own expertise but may introduce
additional risks the following slide
lists the main areas covered in this
knowledge statement the key areas
covered in this knowledge are sourcing
practices is roles and responsibilities
and reviewing contractual commitments
note that these areas have already been
covered in domain 2 governance and
management of IT the sisa candidate
should have knowledge of operations and
and use of procedures for managing
scheduled and non-scheduled processes
operations management is critical in
providing effective efficient and
appropriate technical solutions the
roles and responsibilities of operations
management represent a high risk not
only to the day-to-day running of the IT
organization but to the protection of
information assets both in the areas of
restricting access to authorized people
and the availability of IT the main
areas to be covered here are information
system operations network infrastructure
and implementation reviews and
scheduling reviews we shall look at
information system operations in the
next screen IT operations are processes
and activities that support and manage
the entire infrastructure systems
applications and data focusing on
day-to-day activities infrastructure
operations management is responsible for
accurate and deficient is operations the
tasks of IT operations staff include
executing and monitoring scheduled jobs
facilitating timely backup of computer
files monitoring unauthorized access and
use of sensitive data and monitoring and
reviewing the extensive adherence to IT
others include the operations procedures
as established by is and business
management participating in tests of
disaster recovery plans D RPS and
facilitating troubleshooting and
incident handling we shall continue with
information system operations in the
following screen procedures detailing
instructions for operational tasks and
procedures coupled with appropriate is
management oversight are necessary parts
of is control this documentation should
include procedures for operations
monitoring systems and applications
detecting systems and applications
errors and problems backup and recovery
handling IT problems and unresolved
issues among other procedures
let us look at job scheduling software
in the next screen scheduling is making
operations automated without any
attendance the schedule includes the job
that must be run the sequence of the
jobs that must be run the sequence of
job execution and the conditions that
cause problem execution job should be
scheduled according to SLA high-priority
jobs should be given optimal resource
availability while maintenance functions
such as backup and system reorganization
should if possible be performed during
non-peak hours job scheduling software
is software used by installations that
process large number of batch routines
it sets up daily work schedules and
automatically determines which jobs to
be submitted for processing advantages
of job scheduling includes that
information is set up only once
reducing chance of error job
dependencies are defined so that if a
job fails subsequent jobs relying on its
output will not be processed in addition
such software will ensure records are
maintained of all job successes and
failures and there is less reliance on
operations a sisa candidate is expected
to have knowledge of the technology
concepts related to hardware and network
components system software and database
management systems the is auditor must
be familiar with the functionality of
information system Hardware and its
network components this includes
understanding the importance of the
physical part of is IT solutions that
support the organizational objectives
and goals as well as key control and
risks involving system software although
the sisa exam does not test technical
knowledge of the working of individual
components and understanding of the
risks associated with and possible
control functions of each component is
expected an example of this is knowledge
of the risk that router access passwords
may be shared but that if properly
programmed passwords can make a major
contribution to network resilience the
following screen lists the main areas of
coverage in this knowledge
statement main areas of coverage are is
network infrastructure hardware reviews
network infrastructure and
implementation reviews operating systems
utility programs and operating system
reviews let us look at enterprise
network architectures in the next screen
knowledge of enterprise network
architectures is important this is
because today's networks are part of a
large centrally managed internet worked
architecture solution of high-speed
local and wide area computer network in
an organization such networks might
include network segments or blocks which
may include web-based front-end
application servers public or private
application and database servers and
mainframe servers organizations may
implement service-oriented architectures
SOA with web software components using
simple object access protocol SOA ap and
extensible markup language XML within
such an environment information is
highly accessible and available anytime
everywhere and store it centrally let us
learn about the internet and related
terms in our next slide a simple way to
understand the Internet is to look at
what it is comprised of and some key
terms used in relation to the Internet
first the Internet is a vast global
network NW the global network is
comprised of interconnected networks the
purpose of these interconnected networks
is to exchange information
there are also routers to direct traffic
within the networks routers use routing
tables to direct traffic through the
most efficient routes Internet Service
Providers ISPs enable users to connect
to internet networks are connected via
at least lines integrated service for
digital networks ISDN fiber satellite
and regional networks are connected
through network access points an AP no
single person or organization runs the
Internet
it can be said to be an electronic
Anarchy that uses tcp/ip protocol suite
as the de facto standard let us look at
the common terms used in relation to the
internet in the following screen common
terms that you will come across in
relation to the internet include ISP
which stands for Internet service
provider an AP network access point that
connects regional networks traffic
concentration point that refers to a
point of convergence for many ISPs tell
Nettie is a remote terminal control
protocol DNS stands for domain name
service that translates host names into
IP addresses and vice-versa
DNS servers offer the translation
service LAN or mainframes connected to
the Internet providing full access to
the Internet is referred to as a direct
connection let us look at common
internet terms in the next screen online
services allow users to tap the full
power of the internet popular use of
Internet is to download or upload files
this is enabled through the File
Transfer Protocol FTP with anonymous FTP
anyone can get access with user
identification ID and password PW
although this is considered risky Simple
Mail Transfer Protocol SMTP relates to
or facilitates email exchange on the
Internet simple network management
protocol SNMP is a means to monitor and
control network devices manage
configurations performance and Internet
security let us now discuss the world
wide web in the next screen world wide
web or WW is a client-server model where
the client uses a browser for example
Internet Explorer to access a web server
that could be running on NT or UNIX
operating system the world wide web is
the fastest-growing and most innovative
part of the Internet navigation of the
WW is done through typing URL of the
site and use of hypertext links to jump
to other sites worldwide web uses
hypertext markup language HTML for web
pages and hypertext Transfer Protocol
HTTP for web server browser
communication
let us continue to look at common terms
in relation to the world wide web in the
following screen world wide web terms
that you will come across include common
gateway interface CGI scripts this is an
executable machine independent software
program that can be accessed by a web
page to perform specific tasks cookies
help a web page to remember preferences
a cookie is a message sent from a web
server to a browser to identify users
and prepare customized pages applets are
downloaded from web servers to execute
in browsers for example to generate
input forms in the following screen we
look at the client-server model and its
related terms in a client-server
architecture an application is split to
run on different computers some on the
client and some on the server these
tasks are mutually dependent on the
client side the graphic user interface
can be thin or thick the server is
usually a multi-user system such as
mainframe mini computer or personal
computer some of the server functions
include file print database
communication back simile etc advantages
if client-server architecture includes
distributing work among computers and
sharing of system and data resources in
the following screen we will discuss
different tiers of client-server
architectures and middleware a
multi-tiered architecture can be used to
show how tasks are shared among
computers at the graphic user interface
through business rules and application
logic and database levels there are
different client-server architectures
these include two tier 3 tier and
multi-tiered more than two tiers let us
look at two tier architecture in the
following screen in a two tier
client-server architecture there is a
client for example graphic user
interface and business rules which
forms the front-end and the database
server which forms the back-end
limitations of this architecture include
a fat client syndrome for example big
complex programs requiring more memory
and CPU and this architecture is not
highly scalable for example problems
arise when more users are added let us
look at three-tiered architecture in the
following screen in a three-tiered
client-server architecture the front-end
is represented by a graphic user
interface while the back-end is
comprised of the application and
database servers advantages of this
architecture compared to a 2-tiered
include a thin client and it's more
scalable for example can support
thousands of users let us discuss
middleware in the following screen
middleware manages interaction between
the graphic user interface and servers
by offering identification security
authorization and directory services
this in turn supports communication
between clients and servers load
balancing failover component management
and queue management in the next screen
we cover uses of middleware in the
transaction processing monitors
middleware used to handle a monitor
database transaction mainly does load
balancing middleware in object request
broker o our B technology enables use of
shared reusable business objects in a
distributed environment for example
CORBA and Microsoft's comm D comm in a
remote procedure call RPC middleware is
the protocol that enables client to
execute a program on the remote computer
server
lastly in messaging servers middleware
programs asynchronously prioritized
queue process messages using dedicated
servers let us look at risks and
controls of middleware in the following
screen the major risk of middleware is
loss of system integrity from multiple
operating environments and lack of
change control however controls that can
be used to manage this include
testing systems adequately managing
modifications and versions in the next
screen we move on to our computer
hardware the diagram on the screen shows
a broad classification of computer
hardware components and the
communication between the input
processing and output components of a
computer input devices are used to
capture data and information into the
central processing unit of the computer
the central processing unit comprises of
the arithmetic logic unit registers and
the main memory the diagram also shows
that the central processing unit is
connected to the output devices through
which processed data and information is
communicated to the user a secondary
storage is also connected to the main
computer central processing unit each of
these components is explained further in
the following screens the central
processing unit forms the processing
components of a computer there is an
arithmetic logic unit which performs
mathematical and logical operations a
control unit and the internal memory
used for processing transactions input
and output components past transaction
information to the computer and display
or record the output generated by the
computer computer peripherals such as
the keyboard and mouse are input only
devices whereas printers form output
only devices other components of a
computer include motherboard random
access memory or a.m. and read-only
memory are OEM let us now look at types
of computers in the following few
screens computers can be categorized
based on several criteria mainly
processing power size and architecture
the different categories include
supercomputers high-end and mid-range
servers mainframe mini computer personal
computers pcs or microcomputer notebook
laptop computers smartphones and
personal digital assistants PDAs
supercomputers are very large and
expensive computers with
highest processing speed used for
specialized purposes use complex
mathematical or logical calculations for
example huge computing power is used to
determine weather patterns such as
probability of tsunami or earthquake
occurring in a given location high-end
and mid-range servers are multi
processing computer systems capable of
supporting thousands of simultaneous
users these computers differ from
mainframes by virtue of being less
expensive the higher end ones utilize
uni operating system OS and may be used
as database servers while the lower end
ones utilize Windows OS and may be used
as application print servers mainframe
computers are large general-purpose
computers operating in a multi-user
multi processing environment and usually
serves thousands of internal external
users many computers are used by
mid-sized organizations and operate in a
multi-user
multi processing environment personal
computers pcs also known as micro
computers are small inexpensive
computers referred to as pcs or
workstations and designed for individual
users they are inexpensive and use
microprocessor technology notebooks
laptop computers are lightweight under
ten pounds five kilograms personal
computers powered by normal AC
connection or rechargeable battery pack
they are preferred because of their
portability however local area network
by being portable they are vulnerable to
theft or connectivity hijacked in a land
wireless connection etc smartphones and
personal digital assistants PDAs are
small handheld digital devices the size
of a calculator also known as palm tops
used as a personal organiser and
planners telephone fax have networking
capabilities and can interface with
personal computers and are used for
field data collection and for
communication they use pen based stylus
instead of keyboard they can also be
used as schedulers phone address book
to-do lists and for office automation
spreadsheets text editor
for example msword some have handwriting
recognition capability in the next
screen we will continue our discussion
of computer hardware and architectures
and learn about peripheral devices
computer peripheral devices include
input/output devices audio video cards
CD ROMs read-only memory DVDs tape
drives disk drives printers and modems
some commonly used computer
terminologies include the following
multitasking which refers to running of
two or more tasks concurrently by
allocating time slots slices to each
task multi-programming on the other hand
refers to running two or more programs
concurrently multi processing is another
term you just went to or more processors
share memory and execute programs
simultaneously in multi-user or time
sharing environments multiple users
access and use computer and the
operating system simultaneously
multi-threading is describes a process
in which several sub activities take
place when a program is being executed
there are numerous computer hardware
developments that have occurred over
time as we shall see in the next screen
some of the developments in computer
hardware include memory cards flash
drives pen drive write once and read
many worm memory cards flash memory and
universal serial bus USB memory cards
flash drives pen drive are a combination
of USB and memory card technology that
is useful in storing information
however they pose very serious security
risks to the stored data if they are
lost or stolen and can be used to bypass
bootable security checks large amounts
of data and information can be
transferred to flash memory very fast
right once and read many Worm includes
compact discs CDs like the ones used for
music up to 80 minutes and for data
files 700 megabytes compact disc
recordable rewritable CDR cd-rw are
technically not a worm
another example is digital video disc
DVD the
uses optical storage technology with
large capacity gigabytes let us look at
other developments in the following
screen memory cards flash memory are
alternative devices to store information
they are small non-volatile removable
and easy to erase and store data
information in and can be used with
other peripherals like cameras personal
digital assistants universal serial bus
USB is a serial bus standard that
interfaces devices with a host it was
designed to allow connection of many
peripherals to a single standardized
interface sockets and improve the
plug-and-play capabilities by allowing
hot swapping in the next screen we look
at common enterprise back-end devices
print servers which consolidate printing
resources for cost saving file servers
that manage organization wide access to
files and program application program
servers that host applications and allow
users are access to centralized programs
and web servers which provide
information and services to internal
employees or external public customers
through web pages a web server is
accessed using a universal resource
locator URL for example wwl comm it also
utilizes DNS services proxy servers
provide an intermediate link between
users and resources as opposed to direct
access database server is a pro posit
orac containing raw data and
applications web servers process data
for user consumption appliances are
specialized devices like firewall IDs
switches routers that could be used to
support virtual private networks load
balancing etc now let us consider
hardware risks in the next screen
computer hardware is exposed to the
following risks data and media loss loss
of flash drives which may lead to
unauthorized access to data corruption
of data which can simply be caused by
improper unplugging of USB drives
viruses and other malicious software
contained in infected documents and
which can spread via
disks malicious code include keyloggers
to capture passwords for hackers data
theft where hackers corporate spies
disgruntled employees may steal data use
of social engineering to gain physical
access to personal computers losses of
confidentiality that may come as a
result of losing a memory stick with
confidential data this may lead to legal
liability HIPAA requirements for health
information let us look at controls to
safeguard Hardware in the following
screen in order to safeguard computer
hardware against these risks the
following controls can be put in place
encryption fully covered in domain 5
educating security personnel to be aware
of the risk in their environment to
enforce the lock desktop policy duration
based on risk of environment update the
antivirus policy and enforce mandatory
scanning of USB flash drive granular
control using Microsoft Active Directory
group policy to implement controls user
awareness programs for culture behavior
change use only secure devices which
have security integrated into devices
when buying them include return
information include text file with
contact details excluding company name
to allow whoever collects the flash
drive to return it to the owner in the
next screen we look at radio frequency
identification commonly known as RFID
RFID uses radio waves to identify tagged
objects within a limited radius it uses
a tag which is a microchip to store
information with the identification of
the product and an antenna that
transmits information to the radio
frequency identification reader there
are two modes of powering the tags
active tags that are powered by own
batteries utilize higher frequencies
wider communication radius have more
data capacity are reusable but are more
expensive and passive tags that draw
power from the radio frequency
identification reader radiation it has
basic information two kilobytes uses
lower frequencies smaller communication
radius
state of capacity is not reusable but it
is less expensive let us look at the
applications of RFID in the following
screen radio frequency identification
can be used in the following areas asset
management for example in the library
because it does not require optical
line-of-sight tracking authenticity
verification matching for example two
pairs that have to go together avoid
confusion later in process control to
initiate processes based on tag identify
err access control for example
restricted areas and office doors access
and supply chain management
SCM for example tracking from
manufacturer to retail in the next two
screens we will look at RFID risks and
controls radio frequency identification
risks include business process risk
where interference with radio frequency
identification will result to
interference with business processes
business intelligent risk where a
competitor can gain information from
radio frequency identification and use
it to harm the business privacy risk
where personally identifiable
information can be compromised
for example tagged items can be traced
to an individual externality risk where
for example an adversary gains
unauthorized access to computers on an
enterprise network through Internet
Protocol IP via enabled RFID readers if
the readers are not designed and
configured properly to safeguard against
these risks security controls that can
be put in place include management
oversight for example by way of
implementing policies operational
controls for administrators and users
for example physical controls and
technical for example using technology
to monitor usage in the next screen we
briefly look at hardware maintenance
program hardware must be routinely
cleaned and serviced there should be a
maintenance schedule that coincides with
vendor specifications maintenance
requirements vary based on complexity
and performance workloads maintenance
program should document
reputable service company for each
component maintenance schedule
maintenance cost information and history
planned and exceptional maintenance is
management should monitor document and
justified deviations excessive
maintenance costs are a risk indicator
there are several Hardware monitoring
practices and hardware auditing
practices that can be put in place let
us look at Hardware monitoring practices
in the following screen
these include Arab reports that are used
to record failures and corrective action
taken availability reports that check
for downtime that can be caused by
inadequate facilities excessive
maintenance lack of preventive
maintenance utilization reports
automated that document utilization of
machine and peripherals for instance
utilization of over 85% may indicate
over capacity while utilization of less
than 95% may call for a review of
resource capacity and schedules
Asset Management reports that include
Network inventory for example connected
equipment such as personal computers
servers routers and other devices in the
next screen we will discuss Hardware
auditing auditing of hardware covers
capacity management procedures that
ensure continuous performance and
weather performance management is
objective performance evaluation
procedures availability and utilization
reviews change management controls such
as approval planning scheduling
communication minimize impact on
business operator documentation and
hardware availability and utilization
reporting in the next screen we look at
information systems architecture and
software information systems
architecture and software components
hierarchy as shown in the first diagram
is as follows the application system
that sits on top of software utilities
and programs which are above the nucleus
that interfaces with hardware and
firmware therefore between the user and
the hardware information system
architecture is defined to include user
application
rating system and hardware interfacing
in that order as is also shown in the
second diagram operating systems OS
makes computing power conveniently
available to clients for example
utilities applications human users the
operating system manages computer
resources including processors memory
disks timers IO devices and data the
following screen offers a detailed look
of operating system functions and parts
functions of the operating system
include holding of programs that
interface between the user processor and
application software provides the
primary means of controlling the sharing
and use of computer resources maintains
the integrity of the system manages and
controls execution of programs and
shields the user the details of the
hardware operating system parts include
kernel or nucleus and utility programs
in the next screen we look at the
operating system nucleus and software as
we continue our discussion on the
computer operating system the operating
system nucleus is a highly privileged
restricted area that runs in kernel mode
supervisory state and resides in the
computer memory all the time other
utilities are called in is needed it
performs the basic functions associated
with the operating system which include
Process Management input/output
Management memory management and file
management in process management the
nucleus does interrupt handling process
creation destruction dispatching process
synchronization and inter process
communication in input/output management
the nucleus manages printers KB's disk
drives CD ROMs and all other
input/output devices connected to the
computer in memory management the
nucleus does allocation and
de-allocation file management which
involves create read write delete open
and close is also done in the nucleus
let us look at OSI Scylla T's in the
following screen operating system for
subtleties include user interface
program execution management file
management for example create delete
read write resource scheduling between
clients input/output support that covers
device independence uniform interface
uniform naming protection against
unauthorized access authentication
access control monitoring
non-interference accounting error
detection and recovery concurrent
processing and data sharing let us look
at oh s software in the following screen
operating system software includes
access control data communications and
database management system program
library management tape and disk
management and network management job
scheduling and utility programs over the
following few screens we will understand
operating system integrity the objective
of operating system integrity is to
protect the operating system from
interference and compromise and to
protect applications from other
applications this involves the operating
system protecting itself from deliberate
and inadvertent modifications and
ensuring privileged programs are not
interfered with by user programs for
integrity process isolation occurs to
ensure that multiple processes are
protected from each other for example
writing into each other's memory and
that there is enforcement of least
privileged supervisory state refers to
the most privileged state with complete
unrestricted access to all system
resources for example memory devices and
privileged instructions and ability to
bypass any security features in place
the kernel operates in this state some
system utilities also operate in this
state making them highly risky requiring
strict control user state is the most
restricted and less privileged state
users address their own restricted
memory space user state relies on code
running on supervisory state to perform
privileged functions applications run in
this state user state is critically
dependent on is management's
authorization techniques and
to prevent non-privileged users from
executing privileged instructions and on
configuration of files directories
registry for options and parameters this
must be controlled configured and
updated properly with latest patches to
avoid compromise by perpetrators for
example IBM 396 one harm live win
registry control features or parameters
allow standard software to be customized
to diverse environments and provide
effective means of determining how
controls are functioning within
operating system control features should
be appropriate to the organization's
workload and control structure activity
logging and reporting is the collection
of specified pieces of information for
purposes of analyzing system functions
activity logging and reporting areas
include date file versions used for
processing accesses to sensitive data
utilities and service aid usage and
database management system efficiency
and security let us now look at access
control software in the following screen
access control software developed for
the computer must be compatible with its
operating system it is designed to
prevent unauthorized access to data use
of system functions and programs and
updates or changes to data the software
is designed to detect and prevent
unauthorized computer access data
communication software is used to
transmit data from one point to another
also used for conversion for example of
codes such as AAS CII ebcdic and unicode
components of communication software
include sender and receiver message and
information to be communicated and the
medium or Channel let us continue
looking at access control software in
the following screen system components
include transmitter source receiver sync
and transmission path channel line it
also includes local area networks lands
and wide area networks LANs applications
here include electron
funds transfer EFT systems electronic
data interchange EDI office information
systems like electronic message systems
bulletin board etc interfaces with
operating system application programs
database management systems
telecommunication systems and network
control systems in the next screen we
will take a look at telecommunication
links telecommunication links or lines
for networks can be either analog or
digital they're classified in several
ways according to the type of provider
or the type of technology they can be
divided into dedicated circuit also
known as leased lines or switched
circuit let us discuss circuit switching
and packet switching in the following
screen circuit switching mechanism is
typically used over the telephone
network plain old telephone service P
OTS for example integrated services
Digital Network ISDN switched circuits
allowed data connections that can be
initiated when needed and terminated
when communication is complete this
works much like a normal telephone line
works for voice communication ISDN is a
good example of circuit switching packet
switching is a technology in which users
share common carrier resources packet
switching allows the carrier to make
more efficient use of its infrastructure
and the cost to the customer is
generally much lower than with leased
lines the next screen covers baseband
and broadband telecommunication links in
baseband networks the signals are
directly injected on the communication
link so that one single channel is
available on that link for transmitting
signals as a result the entire capacity
of the communication channel is used to
transmit one data signal and
communication can move in only one
direction at a time half duplex
communication in a broadband network
different carrier frequencies defined
within the available band can carry
analog signals such as those generated
by image processors or a data modem as
if they were placed on separate
ban channels interference is avoided by
separating adjacent carrier frequencies
with a gap that depends on the band
requirements of the carried signals the
conditions when simultaneous data or
controlled transmission reception takes
place between two stations is called a
full duplex connection let us now turn
to the different types of networks in
the next screen personal area networks
pans is a microcomputer network used for
communications in telephones PDAs
printers cameras scanners among other
computer devices being used by an
individual person local area networks
lands are computer networks that cover a
limited area such as a home office or
campus wide area networks winds are
computer networks that cover a broad
area such as a city region nation or an
international link the internet is an
example the largest example of a when
metropolitan area networks Mane's are
lands that are limited to a city or
region usually Mane's are characterized
by higher data transfer rates than winds
storage area networks sands are a
variation of lands and are dedicated to
connecting storage devices to servers
and other computing devices sans
centralized the process for the storage
and administration of data in the next
screen we will look at wireless networks
which are also a type of network
wireless technologies enable one or more
devices to communicate without physical
connections that is without requiring
network or peripheral cabling the
technology in wireless networks uses
radio frequency transmissions
electromagnetic signals through free
space as the means for transmitting data
whereas wired technologies use
electrical signals through cables
wireless networks serve as the transport
mechanism between devices and among
devices and the traditional wired
networks wireless networks are many and
diverse but are frequently categorized
into four groups based on their coverage
range these
our wide area networks local area
networks wireless personal networks and
wireless ad-hoc networks the following
screen lists the risks of a wireless
network risks of wireless networks
include interception of sensitive
information loss or theft of devices
misuse of devices loss of data contained
in the devices distractions caused by
the devices and possible health effects
of device usage in the next screen we
look at types of wireless networks
wireless wide area network WWAN this is
the process of linking different
networks over a large geographical area
to allow wider IT resource sharing and
connectivity wireless wide area networks
are connected via radio satellite and
mobile phone technologies wireless wide
area network using radio satellite and
mobile phone technologies can complement
and compete with more traditional
systems of cable based networking I
Triple E eight 2.11 s wired equivalent
privacy encryption uses symmetric
private keys which means the end users
radio based network interface card n IC
and access point must have the same key
this leads to difficulties periodically
involved with distributing new keys to
each network interface card with static
keys several hacking tools easily break
through the relatively weak WEP
encryption mechanisms wireless networks
types continue in the next screen Wi-Fi
protected access wpa wpa2 is newer
security protocols that utilize public
key cryptography techniques to provide
effective authentication and decryption
between users and access points wireless
personal area networks WPA ends are
short-range wireless networks that
connect wireless devices to one another
the most dominant form of WPA and
technology is Bluetooth Bluetooth links
wireless devices at very short distances
the oldest way to connect devices in a
WPA and fashion is you
infrared IR communications wireless
network types continues in the next
screen ad hoc networks are networks
designed to dynamically connect remote
devices such as cell phones laptops and
PDAs these networks are termed ad-hoc
because of their shifting network
topologies
whereas WLAN Zoar WPA ends use a fixed
network infrastructure ad hoc networks
maintain random network configurations
relying on a system of mobile routers
connected by wireless links to enable
devices to communicate Wireless
Application protocol W ap is a multi
layered protocol and related
technologies that bring Internet content
to wireless mobile devices such as
personal digital assistants PDAs and
cell phones the next screen discusses
virtual private networks a virtual
private network VPN extends the
corporate network securely via encrypted
packet sent out via virtual connections
over the public Internet to distant
offices home workers salespeople and
business partners virtual private
network allows network managers to cost
efficiently increase the span of the
corporate network they also allow remote
network users to securely and easily
access their corporate enterprise
corporations to securely communicate
with business partners supply chain
management to be efficient and effective
and service providers to grow their
businesses by providing substantial
incremental bandwidth with value-added
services the following screen lists VPN
types the different types of virtual
private networks include remote access
VPN which is used to connect
telecommuters and mobile users to the
enterprise W a n in a secure manner
internet and VPN used to connect branch
offices within an enterprise W a n and
extranet VPN used to give business
partners limited access to each other's
corporate network in the next screen let
us look at network components network
components include Network hosts
transmission media network
infrastructure components and network
software
Network hosts includes servers PCs
printers transmission media includes
fiber coaxial cable and copper UTP cable
among others network infrastructure
components whose significant network
components include servers routers
switches hubs modems and wireless
networks and network software that
provide the rules for exchange and
control of data and process of
communication across the different
components from end-to-end the following
screen lists network services some
network services include file sharing
email services print services remote
access services or terminal emulation
directory services network management
dynamic host configuration protocol DHCP
and domain name service DNS hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simply learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here